hello so I'm Dave Robinson from data cab
I'm gonna be talking about why you
should teach the tidy verse to beginners
this is a topic I've talked a lot about
before on my blog variance explained you
see a couple posts started in 2014
recommending the people teach beginners
ggplot2 rather than built in are
applauding 2016 I shared more about why
I use ggplot2 and then spread my belief
that um really it applies to all the
tidy versity plier ggplot2 tidy are and
the rest of the ecosystem and I bet
you're wondering whether this talk
applies to you and so it's worth
clarifying what do I mean by teaching so
who here will consider themselves a
teacher of our it's a great crowd and I
think I'm a lot of us would imagine
we're thinking of lecturing students so
there's some certainly of some college
professors or high school teachers or
people that um teach are here to
beginners but I'm also referring to a
lot of other ways you can make the
choice of what to teach so for example
you might be evangelizing to coworkers
so I do a lot of this is when I was
working at Stack Overflow or a data camp
trying to figure out how can we onboard
new people into our and it might be in
public speaking or advocacy like here
Lisa Simpson telling everyone they
should use ggplot2 may be the kind of
thing where we are doing a blog post an
analysis we want to get people into data
science and understand how do we get
them in so teaching is not just for
professional teachers so I'll share how
I recommend teaching are and then I'll
go into the why so if I if the fire
alarm went off right now and I would had
to leave I'd be happy as long as I got
this one slide in have goals for what
you want your students to do and start
them doing it as early as possible and
that sounds like it's some kind of
general but has some very specific
implications
one is that order matters you can't just
say well I plan to teach all these
things in the course so I'll teach this
early I'll teach this later you should
put a lot of thought into what the
someone's first
navara is and it also means that when
you teach something you should show why
it's useful immediately not later on so
my goal when I try and get people to use
R is I want people to understand their
data and this is a workflow of a tidy
verse way of working through what kinds
of things you might want to do with data
to import tidy transform visualized
model and then communicate the results
and largely the set of tidy verse tools
are very well suited for each of these
steps so my way of teaching R is kind of
encapsulated in my data camp course
introduction to the tidy verse so you go
to data cap and try taking this course
it has its intended for people that have
never used R or even program before and
it has four chapters first teaching data
wrangling how could you take data and do
what you need to tidy it and bring it
into an analysis it has data
visualization with ggplot2
it moves on to grouping and summarizing
so steps you might do after you've tied
your data but then you can go back to
visualization and and show it in other
kinds of ways so a suit I said that
these are things I want students to do
let's give them a few tools that allow
them to do it I have a follow up more
advanced course called exploratory data
analysis in our case study and that's
meant for people that already have some
experience with R and with the PI R but
it's a very similar approach of I teach
people to clean an ant and transform a
data set to visualize it to model it
using my broom package which works very
well with the apply on ggplot2 and then
to join and tidy that data with with
other data sets so all these courses
this is generally how I really like
thinking I think about the kinds of
package the kinds of parts of an
analysis that students would want to do
and I match the the packages to those
problems so why is the tidy bear so well
suited well consider its powerful people
in a couple lines of code can get a lot
of output this is a graph of my first
course so it's something that we can see
we don't just say
and you'll learn in my week 1 learning
week to learning week 3 on the last day
you'll understand something from your
data here for example students were able
to understand the relationship in
country demographics in just a couple of
lines of code in the first hour of using
our and it's also consistent so the G
that ID versus was largely set up so all
the pieces work together and it works
according to a consistent philosophy so
we will don't have to deal with lots of
um of memorizing little fiddly details
this is one example that I was kind of
really I'm excited to see the FS package
is a is a 1 package within the tidy
verse that works with file system
operations and there already are tools
in fat in the file system that I'm in
are for working with the file system but
they use different naming conventions
because they were added at different
times by different people
lowercase Path thought expand or
camelcase normalized path or capitalized
sistar chmod or file dot access and
these are really difficult for students
because every time they learn something
they have to shift their method of
thinking and it's very hard to memorize
them so the tidy verse has been really
well set up for beginners to get on
board on to it because it uses
consistent syntax so anytime we choose
what to teach first we have to choose
what to leave until later and here
there's some things that people might
consider really important parts of our
that we don't get too early in a course
so one example is data structures
neither these courses talks about what a
factor is how do i how to create a
matrix or even what a list is almost
everything is done on data frames and at
the end atomic vectors it doesn't
introduce loops so there's an example
say a for loop and none of the courses
work with that because they can often be
replaced by a group I in a summarized we
don't teach conditionals these are
considering and they they properly are a
fundamental unit of programming but it's
not included within how we might deal
with data in the tidy verse and we don't
even necessarily introduce users to our
for defining their own functions
are some context where it's some useful
but it's none of these courses would
discuss something like that so these are
the kinds of code you might recognize
from maybe your introductory our course
or your trajectory programming course
some like basic examples of how can we
do an if and how can we create a
function that adds three to a number so
we probably take these kinds of code
examples for granted but take a look at
them they're all useless they're not
doing anything
this is looping through and it's
printing numbers from 3 to 13 through 3
through 12 this is a function to add 3
to a number why would I need that as
opposed to adding 3 here's an if
additional that is printing something
when we introduce these units of
programming we have to avoid these kinds
of examples that aren't alongside an
actual useful example so I think where
is a good place that we can show these
include these in a curriculum I think
are for data science by have they will
come in Garrett Gras lemon is a really
good example of an ordering of how
things can be taught and are so here
there's about 30 chapters of an
introduction to our is all available
online really terrific book a notice
that introducing that writing someone's
own functions is introduced in chapter
19 an iteration with loops and I believe
conditionals as well is introduced in
chapter 21 so everyone knows students do
need to learn these but they didn't have
to be the first things notice they
started with the with data visualization
data wrangling how we tidy data so why
do people teach these kinds of
approaches first why do people feel like
we should teach if and for loops so
who's seen the movie Karate Kid
so in Karate Kid there I think a lot of
people kind of model themselves off this
teacher mr. Miyagi from Karate Kid if
you haven't seen the movie this is where
he is having a student Daniel he's
having him um wax his car and paint his
house and do these other meaningless
chores and then Dan finally gets really
angry about it and it's
only later that he realizes that the
whole time he's been learning karate
without even knowing it so I think a lot
of people think think of a teaching are
that they'll do something similar
they'll teach a for-loop that doesn't
actually do anything useful but then
later when the student needs it they'll
realize that they've been learning
powerful methods all along so I don't
like this approach I think that mr.
Miyagi really was kind of doing Daniel
at a service because as I said my
philosophy would be start people doing
your goals as early as possible so when
so when a beginner walks into a class
what might they be want I want to learn
so typically someone might be in the
crowd and say um well I want to draw
conclusions about my gene expression
data set or maybe they have a psychology
experiment they need to interpret the
results maybe they have an internship
coming up they'd like to analyze data
for their job so these are the kinds of
goals that students gonna walk in and
they're they're ready to put in the work
to learn these things what aren't they
thinking
they're probably not thinking well I
really want to hear what a loop is I've
heard so much about them they're
probably not thinking I need to know the
six types of atomic vectors
no one's going insane if I don't if they
don't talk about function scoping I'm
gonna lose my mind so you're teaching
these things really early on you're
losing students attention and if you
structure your course like this where
you say more progress as more progress
happens you can um start off going slow
but later it all comes together into
something that students can do you're
kind of starting with people saying well
why would I need this and later on
telling them oh I get it now
it sounds like it works consider what if
they quit right here I mentioned that of
the kinds of teaching um you might do
working with co-workers or public Abbess
advocacy in a blog post a lot of them
have non captive audiences nothing
stopping them from quitting with their
busy people they've got jobs to do and
they're not necessarily going to stay to
wait until it all comes together a
better path might be that the further
progress you make in the course the more
can do in a linear trend so people are
always gaining more and more power in
fact you can probably if you're a little
bit clever structure course so it's a
bit front-loaded where you can kind of
follow the 80/20 rule solve 80% of
students problems as early as you can
and then start getting to the details of
other things they might need to do later
in the course
so if sometimes heard the criticism that
perhaps Heidi versus training wheels
it's very good for beginners but how far
can people really get just using the
tidy verse tonight I'd respond that
Julius silky and I wrote a book text
mining with art and the entire thing
goes through many examples of exploring
visualizing and modeling text data and
the whole book doesn't use a single loop
or conditional we weren't trying to
avoid it it's just that you can get a
huge amount done with the tools in the
in the tidy verse so there are
exceptions to rules like this this
really isn't a um isn't it an absolute
and I think there are few good examples
of when you shouldn't teach the tidy
verse first won't be if your core it's
really about what your goals are so I
mentioned before my goal generally would
be get people understanding and
analyzing data but you might have a
different goal one goal your students
could have is they want to learn to
program who they want to build their own
our packages and and then you might
really want to learn things the
fundamentals of programming they can
apply them to other languages for that
I'd it's a very reasonable goal but it
asked two questions one is why are you
choosing our our isn't necessarily the
best first language to learn if someone
if you want to teach programming
fundamentals because it's usually used
for one particular domain understanding
data and because it there are some
things in other languages like for loops
that can be very bad habits in are
because of the way that their language
is designed another is are you sure that
students are as interested in writing
and publishing packages as you think
that they are so this is a crowd of very
committed people that have all really
been a is really quite selective people
that care a lot about our we're here on
a
Saturday can you raise your hand if
you've ever submitted a package to cram
so consider that even in a crowd like
this most people don't feel the need to
write their own packages or to publish
them so sometimes teachers will start
and say well I think everyone's gonna
want to build code other people can use
maybe they don't maybe they want to
understand their own data another goal
could be mathematical understanding if
you want to learn to teach things like
PCA you want to teach them iein spaces
you want to teach things about how
people can um can really model and and
do sophistical understanding of data
from the mathematical approach the tidy
verse may not be the right start the
philosophy is still true you want to
teach things as have the goals and teach
them as early as you can you probably
start by teaching matrices before
teaching data frames you'd probably
teach linear algebra before you teach
the methods of relational algebra that
being group by and joins and really kind
of sequel syntax that deeply are
imitates so really you can see it's
described by a different kind of
vocabulary and here's a case we might
want to teach the abstract before the
concrete because the abstract is what
you actually want the students to
understand if you are picking a case
study it might really be secondary and
might not reflect what the UM what goals
you're hoping to get across and the
students so think if you're aiming to
teach programming or Amy to teach math
and you're sure that's your goal those
are some valid reasons not to teach the
tidy verse first so what's next for me
this year is in January I joined data
camp and here we have a really terrific
set of data about how people learn so
I'd like to wouldn't plan some work to
get evidence behind this and get a
really good understanding of how people
can actually learn or what kinds of
mistakes they make and how we can help
students through it leading to a process
we're calling data-driven curriculum
development I look forward to talking a
lot about that this year and if you want
your team to learn the tidy verse if you
want to kind of spread it and you think
this is a good philosophy a really good
way to do that is data camp for business
so response we and we have salmon
over there that are Manning the data
camp booth and you should absolutely
talk to them my course untidy verse our
exploratory data analysis a ton of great
people's of course is like Max Q and as
of course andreas Miller has a course
there's lots of material in terms of to
get people to UM to learn and do things
in in both R and Python and it's a
really good way to lead your team so
absolutely talk to the data cab people
afterwards about how we can help your
team with learning and if you're
interested in being an instructor and
you want to teach data science to a huge
audience over two million registered
users you should go to data Capcom slash
create and we apply to become an
instructor so this I think is a really
good crowd for people that you might
have something that you're an expert in
and you might be able to communicate and
I'd be really excited to talk to you
about that afterwards thank you
you
you